Michael you recently had the chance to
play all of those VR games yep were they
fun let's get into it right now alright
so first up but des denounced fallout 4
BR III last year you had a chance to
play it you know how was it so I got to
explore as much as I could in the short
time period I got to play but it works
out really well actually one thing that
stood out to me was being able to
control Pip Boy by just raising us all
on you eyes on your yeah and I was
playing on five so with a little dial I
could either use the the pip-boy itself
or I can use the dial to scroll through
my items another the great thing that I
experienced was the bat system it just
slows it down and then it becomes free
aim so I could just aim at the enemy
it's like the whole time yeah it's
almost like a bullet time and it'll
highlight each body part that I'm
targeting but I won't give me no
percentages I just pull the trigger so
it makes that game a little bit easier
in a sense because you know when you get
into a battle it could be very jarring
it could be hard to kind of get a
controller situation but I think that
the way they're implementing Phat's this
time around is going to work really well
for it so the game's kind of been like a
hybrid between action gaming like an RPG
did it feel much more like an action
game now that you're actually ducking
and actually using your physicality yeah
a little bit in the sense of the
gameplay I'm not sure how extensive it
is in terms of like stats and building
out my character that remains to be seen
gotcha and then how did you move around
the game the teleportation so I would
just like continually so in there option
if you wanted to just use like if I were
to locomote yeah if I recall correctly I
think there was an option for artificial
locomotion but I'd have none of that man
that makes you that tends to make a
little bit more motion let's move on to
the next game you also tried doom VFR
yeah which I assume is like named after
it was The BFG yeah to get it with the I
think there but you know how was that
that also worked surprisingly well
because I thought that doom VFR was
gonna be too fast for me and when that
happens that's kind of what throws me
off and yeah you get motion sick yeah
but the teleportation worked really well
I'm like a - yeah it's like it's like
dashing well there's two things there's
a teleportation and then I could - with
the dial so it'll move my character I
was out straight yeah like strafing and
that surprisingly didn't I didn't throw
me off so it was really smooth playing
on vibe again
and the one thing that stood out to me
is the glory kills so you do shoot your
enemies in a high light but the way you
do glory kills is that you teleport at
them and you see yourself almost like
shoulder bump them and they just like
fall apart so the glory kills are really
cool in VR they works well interacting
with my environment it was uh you know
nothing too special but it was fun and I
got to cycle through try out the
different weapons and it all tracked
well and it was surprisingly fast and it
didn't make me want to throw up and then
the last vo game which was kind of a
surprise with Skyrim VR announced for
get PSP or and I believe this is also
coming to the vibe next year yeah I
played on PSP R but I asked it's coming
in to other platforms they confirmed
that it is coming to HCC 5 and 2018 and
again another surprise of how well it
worked the cool thing about it was that
everything I equipped like the sword I
could like actually slash and have like
pull a trigger to actually do the action
so I was like slicing enemies and uh
also had my spell my other hand all yeah
so I was like shooting flames out my
hand I feel like a Jedi yeah yeah so
like my magic spells was really cool
because I could actually free aim
everything so it works well in psvr but
I'm excited to see how well it can look
on PCs cool and then last question do
you have a favorite game you had to say
right now if I to say right now I'm
excited to return to Skyrim even like
six years after after yeah it's kind of
people are saying it's convenient
Deadhorse but does it keeps me any
buddies in the game but if you haven't
played the or if you haven't really
tried this games in VR it actually feels
much more immersive it feels like you're
in Skyrim yeah that's true I'm really
jealous anyways for more game tech
coverage subscribe to us on youtube if
you like this video give it a thumbs up
thanks for watching
[Music]